[Music]
Car No. 86 is a challenger from the UK, Kanata
Katagiri, 19 years old. It's a
lie, it's from Canada. I can't
believe it was my father's entry from Katagiri. I'm happy just to be able to experience the MFG.
Who am I? After all, I went to a prestigious British
racing school.
Only 15 out of 302 entries will be able to participate in the finals.Fujiwara
's student will
earn the top prize of 100 million yen.If he wins the overall championship for the year, he will
get a bonus and even more China
[Music]
15 monster cars.  Direction My purpose
is to take on challenges, not money. What can I
do for the other side? I
won't lose to the Europeans. Let's show off our Yamato spirit.
Grip Eight Ratio. Make it even smoother.
Don't step on the accelerator. Someone's in your ear.  Whisper, the only thing I need to do is
update that car.
[Music]
Why do I feel miserable, like I'm being looked down on from a high place? Are
you qualified to buy that car? Just for the sake
of a girl.  If you don't use it anymore, you'll just have to risk your life to
earn it again. If you're
quick enough, Honda will beat you and follow you. He's surprisingly tough. Help me, big brother. The timing for me to join that battle may be unexpectedly early.
Should I loosen it up? No, runny nose.  It's out